et au deuxième jour de cette nouvelle
année l'Ukraine vit toujours en rythme
intense bombardement après un nouvel an
rythmé par des dizaines de frappes
russes une nouvelle attaque aérienne a
visé Kiev ce matin une quarantaine de
drones ont été abattues selon les
autorités qui déplorent d'importants
dégâts notamment dans le district de
destinyanski dans le nord-est de la
capitale on trouve notre envoyé spécial
à Kiev Mélina Huet Mélina bonjour quelle
est la situation au moment où l'on se
parle
tiens vous l'avez dit Elisabeth hier les
sirènes ont à nouveau retenti à kiffent
la capitale où nous nous trouvons avec
des énième frappes il faut savoir que
dans la capitale depuis le 28 29
décembre les frappe continue sans
discontinuer toute la journée mais
également toute la nuit avec des alertes
aériennes constantes encore ce matin
l'armée ukrainienne annonce avoir abattu
39 drones kamikazes de fabrication
aériennes deux drones d'observation et
au moins un missile ça intervient vous
l'avez dit au lendemain d'un nouvel an
un petit peu spécial vu qu'il y a eu
encore des frappes toute la nuit la nuit
du 31 au 1er la nuit du 1er au 2 janvier
nous avons passé la soirée du 31
décembre avec une maman et ses deux
enfants qui ont passé le nouvel an tout
seul et pour cause le mari de cette
femme est mobilisé sur le front lorsque
nous l'avons quitté et bien de nouvelles
explosions ont été entendues c'est le
système de défense entière qui
fonctionnait au-dessus de la ville de
Kiev mais certains n'ont pas
d'abriantérien n'ont pas de caves et
donc cette femme par exemple à passer la
nuit avec ses deux enfants sur le palier
dans le hall de leur immeuble pour se
prémunir d'éventuelles nouvelles frappes
c'est la réalité un des Ukrainiens nous
avons également passé du temps à
l'approche de minuit avec des jeunes qui
essayaient tant bien que mal de célébrer
chez eux puisqu'il y avait un couvre-feu
qui était maintenu ils ont regardé la
locution du président volody mers
zellenski qui s'est entretenu pendant
plus qui s'est entretenu avec le peuple
dans une allocution préenregistrée
pendant plus de 15 minutes beaucoup
d'émotions lors de cette allocution il a
parlé évidemment de l'état de sidération
au premier mois de la guerre et puis de
comment les Ukrainiens se sont relevés
ont tenté et bien tant bien que mal de
repousser l'agresseur il n'a oublié
aucune région tous les oblast ont été
cités et à la fin ce que ce qui nous a
marqué c'est vraiment tous ces
Ukrainiens qui nous disent que leur
unique veut évidemment pour 2023 c'est
que la paix arrive qu'il chasse enfin
les Russes hors de leur territoire mais
qui récupère aussi les quatre
territoires annexés les deux territoires
du Dombasle la place de louance qui est
de deniès mais également la région de
rerson de zapuridja et distillent ils
veulent reprendre la Crimée qui a été
annexée en 2014 Mélina a eu étant direct
de Kiev pour France 24 Merci à VOUS
Mélina